AS HE TURNS AND FINDS NURK AT
THE RIM.
HE'LL DUMP IT IN. CORNER.
SIMONS INTO THE LANE, UP AND IN.
AND DRILLED A THREE. TO
THE CUP FOR THE EASY TWO-HAND
JAM. 107-105, YOU HEAR
CHAUNCEY BILLUPS TO SIMONS FOR
OUTSIDE IS ALEC BURKS.
WAY, HE WENT HELICOPTERING
THE TOP OF TRENDON SECOND. SHOON
THE WAY TO THE GLASS, LAYING IT
IN AND IT ALL WORKED OUT HE'S BH
THAT THREE. COMES -- ROBINSON, D
JAM.
>> Lamar: GO, GO,
HART WILL BRING IT OUT OF
BACKCOURT, LAYS IT IN, IS SO
>> Kevin: ELIJAH HUGHES, NICE
TOUCH, 15-FOOTER. HIT
A STEPS BACK AND SCORES.
>> Lamar: THAT'S A GOOD SHOT. R,
AND SHREDS WALKER AND LAYS IT SE
AFTERNOON, 5-10N
TRAFFIC, FINDS McLEMORE, NOTES
A THREE, GOT IT.
AND IN WITH A LITTLE FRIENDLY
THE BLAZERS ON THE DIVE, AND
NURK WITH THE JAM ANDRKS TRIGGET
IT. TRIPLE, OH, THAT
WAS COLD! HAS 23 AND THE BALL MT
>> Lamar: THAT'S A GOOD MOVE.
THAT'S A GOOD MOVE.WAS ABLE TO D
LAY IT HOME, AND THE BLAZERS
LEAD BY FIVE. SCORES!
AND THE BLAZERS LEAD